I was uh probably
you know the 16th choice or Captain
America big risks can have big payoffs
but maybe more often they end in epic
fails auditions for professional actors
are no exception and these Stars know
firsthand stick around for 15 auditions
actors wish they could forget when I was
um 12 I auditioned for all that do you
know all that number one we've seen Tom
Holland in more than a few big roles now
but this one seems almost unexpected I
think John boyega which is better for
the role than me when he was asked to
audition for the role of Finn in Star
Wars episode 7 the force awakens Tom
struggled with the audition but it
sounds like it wasn't nerves that got
the best of him Tom explains I remember
my audition for Star Wars I was like
four or five auditions in and I think I
was auditioning for John boyega's role I
remember doing this scene with this lady
bless her and she was just a drone so I
was doing all of this like we gotta get
back to the ship and she was going
bloop I just couldn't stop laughing
number two ask anyone who has done one
and they'll probably tell you that no
one likes auditioning we think lizzo
would agree she said I'm not good at
auditioning I'm like put me in the scene
don't ask me to audition just write it
for me she arrived at this conclusion
after her audition for the role of
Ursula in The Little Mermaid flopped
Liza got the chance to have a
conversation with the actor who did get
the role of Ursula though she ran into
Melissa McCarthy at nadelle concert hi
I'm Melissa and I was like I also
auditioned for Ursula and she was like
well why the hell did I get the part and
then I was like girl because my audition
was terrible I'm a very busy woman and I
haven't got all day it won't cost much
just your voice number three Timothy
chalamet seemed a little under the
weather when he auditioned to play
Spider-Man in the MCU the role later
went to Tom Holland but not before
chalamet had his less than fun audition
experience he explained I read twice and
I left sweating in a total panic I
called my agent Brian swordstrom and I
said Brian I thought about this a lot
and I have to go back and knock on that
door and read again chalamet thought he
hadn't done a good job his agent
cautioned to me against going into the
room and ultimately chalamet did not get
the role number four Jake Gyllenhaal
failed his quest of audition for the
role of Frodo in Lord of the Rings and
well they said they need a hobbit we
thought Jake he describes his audition
experience saying the first scene had no
lines and was simply staged directions
that told him to look at the ring not
knowing the context Jake didn't realize
the gravity of the scene and glanced
over the imaginary ring in a casual and
almost flippant fashion so I sort of
like walked up and I like sort of opened
it up and I was like
is that good he did get to speak in the
other audition scenes but similarly
misunderstood the audition when he
didn't prepare an accent for the role
director Peter Jackson allegedly joked
with him saying you are the worst actor
however he's like did anyone tell you're
supposed to have an accent number five
just because you're auditioning to play
a pirate doesn't mean you should get
into the Grog too early this audition
experience almost sounds like a method
actor preparing the night before his
audition for William Bill Turner and the
Pirates of the Caribbean Act Dr Tom
Hiddleston went out partying Hiddleston
admitted he got drunk the night before
to celebrate a friend's final exams and
was hungover at his audition the next
day but he was up against more than just
a hangover Tom had received the script
only the day before and hadn't even
memorized his lines
number six Full House of dragons sorry
we had to auditioning for the role of
Daenerys in Game of Thrones was less
than fun for actor Elizabeth Olsen right
I auditioned for Game of Thrones who
described her experience saying that she
auditioned for the assistant to the
casting director and did the Khaleesi
speech when she comes out of the fire
and calling her audition awful and that
was the furthest I got it was that bad
number seven the Star Wars movies have
played host to a number of peculiar
characters so it's no surprise to hear
that Eddie Redmayne found himself
auditioning for one and he describes his
audition experience as having made a
fatal mistake he says he put on a
ridiculous voice that was a really
hilarious moment because it was Nina
Gold who I have to thank a lot because
she's cast me in several films and she
was just sitting there and I was trying
again and again with different versions
of my
bye
voice and after like 10 shots she's like
you got anything else I was like no Adam
Driver got the part which was great for
not only the Star Wars universe but the
universe generally number eight it turns
out she's not all that actor Emma Stone
could have been a cast member on all
that but wasn't prepared enough for her
audition she thought she'd be given
sketches but five minutes before she was
told she needed to have three characters
prepared so I was like okay and then I
made up a couple of characters but in
the face of the prepared competition it
was just not enough to get her a role we
are still all that to us Emma number
nine for a superhero sometimes it all
comes down to the costume John came so
close to Landing the title role of
Captain America that he made it as far
as the costume fitting it's a pretty big
day for me his big fail moment came
after the audition and during the
costume fitting Jon describes trying to
get the costumes past his hips when
Chris Hemsworth passed and said all
right mate and I went I'm good this is
stupid
John jokes that he immediately started
taking the suit off saying he was just
like jacked he was like you're gonna
look great in that suit and I was like
don't make fun of me Hemsworth number
10. Casino Royale was a big gamble for
actor Henry Cavill he describes his
audition for the role of James Bond in
the movie saying I probably could have
prepared better in the audition Henry
describes reenacting a scene from a
prior James Bond film where Bond wore
only a towel I remember the director
Martin Campbell saying looking a little
chubby there Henry I didn't know how to
train or diet and I'm glad Martin said
something because I respond well to the
truth it helps me get better how do you
take your Martini just shaking not stood
number 11 could you imagine Eight Mile
with Seth Rogen Seth missed out on a
role in Eminem's hit movie because he
started giggling during his audition he
explains that he auditioned twice
because his first audition failed to
impress the casting director with his
rappery dialogue Seth was asked to bring
someone with him to the second audition
he came back having brought Jason Siegel
with him Seth said we asked our agents
if our auditions could be scheduled one
right after the other so that one of us
could audition for cheddar with the
other reading the Rabbit part and then
we'd switch but Rogan got a case of the
giggles at the audition and couldn't
shake it off at all number 12. what do
Borat and Puss in Boots have in common
Prince Caspian of course actor Nicholas
Holt had a rough time with his audition
for the role of Prince Caspian and the
Narnia series the actor called The
Audition one of my all-time worst saying
he was asked to do a Spanish accent and
modeled it off of Puss in Boots from
Shrek Nicholas explained I was trying to
do my Antonio Banderas impression saying
I am Prince Caspian it was horrendous it
sounded more like Borat number 13. in an
audition there's a fine line between
doing it your way and doing it the way
the casting director wants to see it
actor Eddie Redmayne walked that line
during his audition for Bilbo in The
Hobbit and didn't want to um you know
just do my usual boring thing Eddie said
he tried to copy the way that Ian Holmes
play the character in The Lord of the
Rings my name is
[Laughter]
he was stopped and told to use his own
voice I never got a call back number 14.
maybe she didn't have enough Shades
actor Lucy Hale said she was naive when
she auditioned to play Anastasia in
Fifty Shades of Gray Hale said that she
was mortified by her bad audition in
which she read a very sexually forward
monologue and didn't even really know
what I was saying number 15 Starstruck
in an audition it happens just ask Jamie
Foxx who is up for the role of Rod and
Jerry Maguire fox said that he was so
Starstruck by Tom Cruise in his second
audition that he messed up badly enough
to make Tom laugh at him Jaime said that
at one point Cruz took a dramatic pause
and he thought he just lost his place
and pointed out where they were at
another Point Cruz was speaking softly
and fox asked him to speak up needless
to say Jaime wasn't a match and didn't
get the role in the end
auditions can feel like something
between a casino game and a test of
skill leaving plenty of broken hearts in
their wake but at least we have some
funny fails to share now we know there
must be plenty more hidden gems of
audition stories out there so what do we
miss do you have any audition fail
stories let us know in the comments